coupe décision prise par les nouveaux
dirigeants du football français qui
jouent l'apaisement et qui ont comblé
par ailleurs un vide
aimé jacquet l'homme tranquille succède
à gérard houllier à la tête de l'équipe
de france christophe duchiron on
s'attend bien lu 9h changement et voilà
qu'on nous propose du neuf avec des
vieux routiers aimé jacquet 52 ans ex
numéro 2 de l'équipe de france devient
calife à la place de l'ancien khalife
bonsoir monsieur jacquet bonsoir tout le
monde
si vous le permettez je voudrais revenir
un tout petit peu en arrière bien
revenons en arrière avant d'être
l'adjoint de gérard baudoux aimé jacquet
était l'entraîneur du grand bordeaux à
la fin des années 80 en juillet 92 le
voile avec l'équipe de france avec les
bleus depuis un an et demi il a tout vu
tout connu le meilleur comme le film
noël le graet devait nommer un
intérimaire apparemment aimé jacquet est
là pour durer
tous les entraîneurs sont des
intérimaires à plus ou moins longue
échéance
j'essaie d'être le plus longtemps
possible intérieur pour durer aimé
jacquet un objectif qualifier l'équipe
de france pour le championnat d'europe
en 1996 avec des joueurs nouveaux sans
doute
on lui souhaite en tout cas de ne pas
faire du bluff avec les vieux aimé
jacquet raisons de penser que les
entraîneurs sont des intérimaires
le compte à rebours est commencé